congratulations professor donna
strickland thank you and welcome to this
little foggy part of the city hole you
often mentioned the importance of having
fun that's right at work and please tell
me what's so cool and fun about these
lasers well of course these types of
lasers are the ones that people want to
use as cat toys have three - mine
brightens up because if you actually
have one like this and you've played
around your cat will go crazy try to
chase this yeah that's a green one yes I
have the green one the red one doesn't
matter cat doesn't care
no that's one I mean the lasers I have
in my lab are more intense and they can
take one color and turn into rainbow of
colors just in a glass of water it's
really quite a spectacular thing to see
yeah again I can imagine it's not a
coincidence that lasers fed the
Hollywood with super forces and swards
then yes but usually they don't show
them in the correct way no the correct
way well the thing about lasers is that
it goes in a straight line this is why
we have smoke in the room if you don't
have smoke you don't see it and yet they
use lasers like there's some kind of
sword and a purse there's no like going
sideways it's all going forward you you
ask your students if they played with
Lego as kids why well I guess because I
played with Lego and I think that the
building blocks to the lasers the type
of lasers I play with usually have
mirror mounts that are just about hand
size we have to tweak knobs and very
carefully until you it's precision and
you have to have the patience but you're
also having building blocks to make the
final laser system hmm so it's like
playing with Lego when you started with
lasers it was quite a hot topic and is
even hotter now where do you think
lasers will take us what what benefit
for mankind can you see in the future
well you know people would say
electronics was the technology of the
20th century that's how we got to
computers and everything else but
photonics is really going to be the
technology of the 21st century it's
already getting there people don't
realize that Google centers have a
million Li
and every one of them just to get the
data to move around you don't make a
long-distance phone call without a laser
there's just a myriad you don't go to
the grocery store anymore not scan your
groceries using lasers surgeries are
being done with lasers they're now
everywhere and the pulses are getting
shorter the intense he's always getting
higher more and more things to be done
so we just seen the beginning that's
right I was like that's right I heard
you got an advice from a former Nobel
laureate Bill Phillips what to talk to
the Queen about this evening yeah and
his suggestion was that you should share
your peach I couldn't believe that
because this past summer good friends of
ours brought scientists a dan kleppner
and his wife be from and he's a famous
physicist at MIT and I just thought oh I
get us what am I gonna do with a famous
physicist in my house and I was a little
aghast that I would have this famous
person and my friends
Roberta box - Oh make sure you just
serve your peach upside-down cake
they'll love it and next thing you know
I find out he's telling Bill Phillips
about it it's crazy the recipe down no I
have prepared a pen and a piece of paper
for use I look it up in my book it's
time you know you're sitting next to the
king and I think is a big fan of cakes
so I didn't actually bring the recipe
I'm sorry but it's it's pretty simple
you have to Google enough you just it's
all in one thing and you pour it in the
pan and you're done it's the easiest
recipe known to mankind
have a lovely evening professor sister
thank you very much thank you